[Music]
three times the Flyers have visited the Carell
Center three times they've come away Victorious
they look to make it four for four here tonight
now in order to get into first place you have to
have everybody performing well and that includes
the backup goal tender and gar snow for the
Philadelphia fers has come up so big that he's
starting his fifth game in the last six contest
for the Flyers here tonight and Gary he deserves
to get the starts he's been redot no absolutely he
has been excellent uh whenever it called upon and
for the Flyers to go for him to go 14 games out
a loss that has been unbelievable but it hasn't
always been that way he started off one five and
one was very frustrated but boy did he turn things
around they're young they're enthusiastic they're
playing with a lot of grit and determination and
that's what the team needs and they're led by a
couple of stars of Yashin and Elson two guys that
are excellent in their game [Music] plan gar snow
fifth start in the last six games he saves the
puck more than 91% of the time opposed by Ron
tuget because of the injury to Damen rhods faced
the flyers in the game between these two clubs
about two weeks ago MIT Meo for the third time in
the last four games the referee as the Flyers and
Senators as's a look at players not performing
Dyke house is getting very close Samuelson out
but the second game of his suspension and there is
a look at the Ottawa scratches the most important
one Damen rhods out with a cap injury not believed
to be serious but their starting go tender will
miss this oneair behind the lind red the shot
that deflected off of the defenseman Jason York
greenber gets back to it greenber turning it
toward the net save byair SCS John lir right
where he scores a lot of goals on the door step
it's one- nothing Philadelphia and again the
Legion of Doom cycling the puck finding the open
man and Michael renberg he just Waits Waits and
there lindross on a tip pass to John lir a lot
of attention focused on lindross and John lir
was open you know when you send two guys to to
follow lindross a lot of times the big guy number
10 is wide open and he makes no mistake with a
turnover racing in Shan mcer and the shot the
score the Senators come back just 10 seconds later
and tie it up at one off the neutral zone turnover
by Philadelphia mchan who has tremendous speed
he out raced everybody and tied the game very
quickly and oh boy mcran he's got the head up and
he put that right where he want to do firers win
the draw coffee quick shot he scores Paul coffee
just firing one off the face off tug nut appeared
to duck and it went in two to one Philadelphia
now it's been 14 games for Paul cop coffee but he
snapped that one and I'll tell you what there was
not a lot of time to release it watch this quick
draw and I mean coffee has to unloaded and why
Damien ducked that's tug or tug KN rather why he
ducked in that play the way that looks would you
see it is that he was ducking to get out of the
way but he was screened didn't really see where
the buck was coming from F's looking for more as
clatt is dumped and the penalty is upcoming
penalty on AO upcoming Flyers have the puck
delayed call as de jard plays it in the corner
for more it for spota he was shouldered off by
D and his Ottawa touches up the whistle blows and
the Flyers just regained their lead now go to the
power play rore Lind Ross lir up front coffee n
on the points here's Yanni n Bing it to bore Quick
Pass Tolar in front l r shot save tugnut rebound
stopped by tugnut as well and the senator clear
sits along the boards bore able to clear but that
goes right to duaine who moves in duaine the shot
say snow rebound right in front chips it right for
the Senators mckr this is a power play for the F
but Dua sh score shorthanded goal for Ottawa it
is tied at two in a very strange beginning to this
hockey game and that's twice now on on not good
judgment by the hockey club that they've allowed
goals to be scored against them but that uh there
is nobody close to duch Shane he just wristed it
and it found its way in the net so we've had four
goals just over four minutes of play har and hook
that able to back end into the Ottawa Zone back
goes Johnny lockin he'll roll it up the glass T
got a skate on it but moving it up to Senators
Sean Van Allen has the puck heill blasted glub
Saved By snow to reach back to make the Stop and
he'll hang on that is the first save for gar snow
as it the third shot that has scored with their
first two shots and this otwa team and he starts
up Yashin floating one into the Philadelphia Zone
snow will come out of his net play the puck but
it goes to dle dle controlling the puck centering
it mcran shot save snow rebound poke right back to
snow div on top of it l the F the redberg bounces
up his stick today he couldn't pick it up and Lind
Ros do charging up with it Eric ly Rush moves in
across the line turns with his pass to renberg
renberg to llar SC oh Beauty by the Legion of Doom
Tic Tac to it's 3-2 Philadelphia oh my goodness
was that beautiful to watch magnificent passing
by the legion renberg to the Clair and in but
prior to that Lindros was against the wall and
he finds on the spin around right on the stick
of renberg and that's set up a two-on-one eighth
time this year that John lir has scored two goals
in a game a penalty upcoming it's on Ottawa the
late calls s heads to the bench extra attacker
on Terry's pass eludes Lind Ross and so his tuck
nut plays it to whistle blows stopping play and
the Flyers they'll go back to the power play and
both teams are changing players is n it's to start
up n to ouru Howard chuk who's missed five of the
last six with the groin injury spun it to Lindros
Lindros centered it R sh SC power play goal for
Michael renberg off the beautiful setup from
Lind Ross the goals just keep coming it's 4-2
Philadelphia Lind Ross making a nice move here
and on the backand following rberg now renberg
picks that up in traffic and he is a very good
player getting that puck in traffic but any goal
score you notice said renberg he's got the stick
right along the ice it's not halfway up waving in
the air he's giving lindross a Target and Lindros
puts it right on the stick and then renberg knows
what to do with it and we're seeing a change as
Mike Bales has come out UT's been pulled and Mike
bals secondy year Pro 25 years of age we see his
first action of the year re agent sigy back in
94 out of Ohio State Mike Bales the new goenda
oh he not even played 9 Minutes of this game
we've seen six goals a short-handed goal and
three goal tenders here's M checked by d j a got
it behind the night Yin yeah and in front sh the
score Andreas dle it's four to three watch out in
front of the net nobody there dle has time to put
it home and he makes no mistake but that was aided
on the slip by De jardan a lot of Magic In The
Sticks of both teams tonight plus five at least
when the game began drastically here's laqua turn
over to tski in front B shot blocked by De jardan
and CTIC has the maneuvering up with it firing it
in is the Legion of Doom comes back up in the
middle of the line CH Daniels in the check on R
but Andreas dle has it dle one of the goal scores
moves in drop pass Yash and Y shot save another
rebound snow able to hold his ground and cover up
they continue to battle along it's AO centering
to clatt clatt tried to hand off to podin podin on
the board trying to make a move clatt went down AO
picks up the puck back to clatt clatt Turning with
it clatt bumped from behind and too many white
jerseys now around T clatt but the arm is up from
meu and a penalty on Ottawa this will be the third
consecutive penalty on the Ottawa Senators stick
of the IIs Rumble goes to De jardan his pass off
ESC and out of the box is Yashin here you go the
Senators looking to tie it up fires are getting
back Yashin cutting to the spot the shot Sav no
and he hangs on and Yashin the most dangerous
of senators showed why that was a good save by
garow picking that shot from a screen that tski
just tips it out of the zone so things have who
here's a giveaway D shy score just about the same
things have settled down no they haven't da takes
advantage of a GI in at 44 Rumble lost the handle
of the puck and right to D and he made no mistake
the loss of the puck it just went right off his
stick as Rumble was ready to pass it and there
is the eighth goal of the game 44 tie 19 shots
Alexander D he has a lot of skill this is his 23rd
of the year it's a career high racing up with it
he D Shan GS the fly line theane working on Rumble
he was stopped his back but he turns it over today
in front the shotan sa and the rebound deflected
away from Bon who had an empty net yawning and a p
take a shot snow this sa and front again phon got
his SK out Shane has it back shot it dbbl behind
snow but does not go in as snow Dives on top of
it now the toughest game for a goenda scoring
chances it's time for the Ford intermission
report from Ottawa after one period of play
yes that's right just one period of play four four
the Flyers and the Senators well that first period
aside the Flyers have been playing some relatively
solid defensive hockey in recent games of course
a big reason why they are in first place in the
Eastern Conference and one guy who's been playing
very inspired hockey of late has been Chris terion
who is now leading the Flyers defense Corp plus 18
and he's been very physical the Flyers of course
have been looking for physical play from Chris
throughout his career and he's finally starting to
deliver and he certainly realizes that has to be
part of his game well I think in especially in the
division games you know it's getting it's coming
down to crunch time the playoffs are starting
up and uh I think it's a time when you really
have to you it's it's we have 20 games left and
it's a time of the year to pick it up and start
playing and uh I mean if if if I have to to give
myself pep talks and get myself motivated before
games that's what I'm that's what I'm going to do
uh well his lir is 38 from renberg McAn that was
unassisted coffee from lindross on a faceof that
was won by the Flyers do Shane from mcran lir his
second of the game 39th of the Year from renberg
and lindross and then renberg got in the act from
Lind Ross and Howard Chuck on the power play paage
three dle got his 11th from Yashin and mchan and
then D and unassisted tally we had 24 Shots in
that period as we look at the Inside Story see
the 24 Shots 23 scoring chances Flyers again doing
an excellent job in winning [Music] faceoffs joh
Lin Tom torsky the former devil L to the fly line
cofy doesn't see the [__] in his skates now he's
got it clicks it to the boards and lindross is
back to help out Lind checked by Van Allen it's
Van Allen who went down but the puck to mchan
mcran to cworth cworth the shot safe oh penalty
coming up from the Flyers now Lindros in the Box
for roughing makes it up for the glass but not out
York keeps it in behind the net here's D in front
shot but snow got across the make the rebound they
score cworth had a wide open that staring at him
power play goal five for Ottawa back behind the
net there was a takeout and then day comes right
in front of the net now there host of players big
skate may have been in the crease Gary they're
reviewing it or Bon oh no when the puck goes in
the net I think they may have been out of the
crease and that's what the call is going to
stand the goal is going to stand the puck bounces
out and the players are getting out of the grease
so D got that left skate out of there just before
the puck went in quickly checked by Lindros good
work in the defensive Zone by the Flyers captain
alerson knocking a pass down but Lindros picks
it up in across the line lindr drops it off for
renberg renberg centers the shot Lind they score
another Beauty This one belongs to lindross and
it's 5 five tic tac toe and on the stick and
watch again as the legion goes to the attack and
lindross right in front of the net on a another
good pass by Peter saboda you had mentioned about
reden have an adventurous shift we've seen a lot
of adventurous shifts in this game so far oh it
was a uh high-scoring period the Legion of Doom
did a lot of damage look at the points and they
had nine of 11 shots on goal and now they've added
a goal and an assist in this period there are your
up to- dat totals and better keep your fingers in
the buttons downstairs there may be additions
to those totals as the buck is thrown into the
Philadelphia his own 55 game big check by Rumble
watch HS for a good hit by Darren Rumble that's
finishing the check folks well these teams of
course a brief rivalry because the Senators
are only 5 years old but the Flyers have had much
the better of it a 123 and one advantage in this
year the Flyers have won both games including the
win here and you know what we're signifant about
that win here in November 30th that was the
beginning of the 17 game unbeaten streak for
the Flyers honey with to the line is shot Off The
Stick of nma bounces into the corner now is there
head it behind oh L Ross crashes into cnorth I'm
not sure how cnorth stay down his skates there
here's lockin didn't get it by Nimo one hands it
out reaching for it lir he Scoops it up and set
sail for the AWA zone lir now using the strength
all the way around turns it in front nma couldn't
get the shot as alfor got his stick on it hold
down as redur penalty up coming in Ottawa delayed
call here's Nima with a pass toir got it in front
loose p here's the shot too he passes to and the
shot by Howard Chuck missed everything need a chop
that but he'll keep it in play penalty faota to
Lindros in front for R tip and play whistled down
well Eric Lindros has got his game face on and
he's throwing some thunderous checks against the
opposition lindross has certainly been involved
in this game welld deserved refreshment for him
4 seconds remaine to snow takes his spill as he
got the puck up the coffee his pass knock down
by n he finds Lind Ron across the line L it fire
save failed he's just protected himself and making
that stop here's bore power play time down to 25
seconds bore a shot that's blocked back to Coffee
coffee Senter toward the net deflec SC rod brindar
with a power play goal and for only the third time
this year the Flyers have more than one power play
goal in a game this one a big one they lead 65 you
know what made that possible is Lind Ross knocking
the puck out of the air and then it went gently
to rod bremore and he had an easy time putting
it in the net but the passing has been absolutely
outstanding by the Flyers and still Bales couldn't
get over there so mark that as number 11 goal
in this contest welcome back well Gary the
first period eight goals second period three goals
fewer shots in the second period was it a better
defensive period Well the coaches probably would
think so yeah it certainly did tighten up a lot
the the checks were there and in the offensive
zones players paid a lot more attention to the
dangerous areas but uh Jim you know we had talked
a lot about the power play of the Flyers having
to get in gear come playoff time and I would say
for the last five or six games the movement of
the puck has been outstanding and and so for the
third time this year the Flyers scored more than
one goal and uh that that is good news for a lot
of people the coaching staff the players and the
fans to see the fers power play working gaining
The Zone watch lindross just Knocking by by a
checker and I'll stop it right there see bills
he had to be concerned with Peter abota but look
at the Stick of lindross right along the ice and
he just nudges it into the open net that tied it
at five and then the power play which is really
getting untracked with a lot of good movement
very quick passes again it's Lind Ross that's gets
involved with a Paul coffee shooting it hot coffee
right there stop it right there see the deflection
came in this area and while all eyes are focused
this way there's rod bremore and the puckle just
danced to him right in that position and he just
moves it to the forehead and again had a lot of
open net to shoot at and that goal gave the Flyers
the six to five lead so kennyworth is 11th from
dig and [Music] bunk those countries have quite
a rivalry couple years ago they never would have
been a spin in sweet hanging around here's R the
three scores Michael Ren going the wrap around as
his second of the game the Flyers lead at 75 every
time they get the puck it's always a dangerous
situation but Michael renberg from behind the
net showing that speed he was actually his body
was positioned behind the net the Long Reach
reaching out in front and stuffing it there's the
trio rightfully named the Legion of Doom SP Doom
for the opposition that can't contain him uh huge
night for the trio 13 scoring points five goals
that a shot at it it's n gathers pass to cofy cofy
darts up with it a feed for renri he's stripped by
bon bon with the pass to Albertson his pass denied
in the Flyers counter Rush here's lir rumbling in
across the line lir trying to make the move rury
the backhander bails a stick save lro centerman
Watson he is the the captain when it comes to face
offs lindross just topping the puck away from the
C of gets it back Lindros checked renberg to the
pck circles with it to Lindros the shot save bails
mclair staring daggers at him yeah that shot by
Lind Ross was all the result of hard work along
the wall and coming up with that loose Puck Lind
Ross he just moved away from a check he got in a
position where renberg could feed him the puck and
how quickly it got on net ring Bon is back forth
Lo pass intercepted by Lindros couldn't get back
to it with a big swing at the B has it B checked
byair Coffey tried to poke it away fir is still
in the zone with it here's Lindros cutting to the
go Lind the pass toir he scores the hatrick for
John lir a beautiful setup by Lindros it is over
85 Philadelphia as the line just keeps piling
up the points and very unselfish by Lind Ross
I mean there is no way that lindas was going to
shoot on that play he had John lir marked for his
40th when it resulted in a two-on-one and then
John lir once he nudged to Lindros just kept on
going now watch that soft pass I mean that takes
a lot of skill for Lindros just to nudge it over
the defenseman stick watch the softness of that so
John lir could handle it as well here's Rumble is
playing it off the glass 5 Second to remain bails
will come out and play the P fire it to the Center
Ice Area this one is over the Philadelphia Flyers
Storm from behind and beat Ottawa 8 to5 l draw six
points renberg and mclair big nights as well and
gar snow well he just continues to roll along as
he is now 10 and five in his last 15 decisions
a wild one in Ottawa the Philadelphia Flyers
able to overtake Ottawa 85 as the Flyers make it
three straight victories a Legion of Doom a big
part of it as they pile up 15 points career high
for Eric Lindros actually one and five for Eric
Lind Ross a big night for all the line especially
our but I player of the game yeah an outstanding
performance by the line especially Eric Lindros
not only scoring goals setting up plays but also
very aggressive using that size and strength but
it was fun to watch I'll tell you what they just
absolutely dominated every time that line went on
the ice and spelled Doom for the Ottawa Senators
tonight the Flyers using offense to win 85 over
Ottawa the entire crew including our producer
director Brian Cooper and of course my partner
Gary dorer I'm Jim jacks good night from [Music]
Ottawa